again like during high school when i'd
gotten like the one friend that i got
him into ava so he unlike everybody else
like everybody kind of got into anime
like
i i did i was closeted for a while but i
kind of was like
i need to get out of the closet so
i need a i need to try and convince my
friends
that this is an okay thing to watch so
you need to make a youtube video saying
i'm coming out yeah
i'm coming out i like anime exactly
right
so so the one friend that the the guy i
first experimented on
uh he he why are you gonna use this this
terminology jerry
i was experimenting he's just like like
yoga me being
planning every step being like hmm okay
if i show them this anime maybe
they'll like it's like maybe one of them
will like get into it and sure enough
one of them got into it so i was just
like kick
dory so i got so he
just my one friend he really really got
into anime
i'm talking like him and i would come to
school every week
and we would discuss the episodes that
just came out like the night before like
yeah him and i were like
full-on like anime buddies and one night
we were we were drinking at a friend's
place and uh and i and obviously you
know as you do
when you're in high school you get
really shit-faced right of course
um and i was staying at his place and i
had like missed the bus home and
everything so i was like all right i'm
just gonna crash at yours
and it was just him and i and we were
like we should watch some anime like you
know just why not let's just watch some
anime
and he's uh and i don't know how it came
to it but we were just kind of
scrolling through just looking for
something to watch and he's like you
watch this no you watch this now
and uh and i just kind of slowly turned
to him just as a gag i was like
you ever heard of kisses oh
no and he's like no what's that and he's
like i'm like
we should check it out let's just watch
one episode just for shits and giggles
let's watch an episode of kisses so
imagine
he just me and my friend sitting in a
room
just you know six feet apart because
we're not gay
just just bonding over an episode of
kisses over an episode like every incest
moment happens in like porn and it was
worse because
we didn't i don't know how long he was
standing at the door but his little
brother
was standing at the door he was just
watching us watch kisses and we were
like into it too we were like
oh hell yeah we were like these kids
that like microsoft
mind you we were very drunk so we were
like oh yeah i was like who's your
favorite and he's like oh man they're
both
really cute and just you know full like
you you would have thought we were like
making a reaction video we were like
full on commentating the entire
thing oh my god and what was supposed to
be just you know
just for shoots and giggles just one
episode of kisses we binged the entire
series in one night
what yeah oh my god did he enjoy it he
loved it
and that and that was the moment where i
was like this guy's a kid
if joe don't don't go home with joey
drunk yeah he'll try and show you [ __ ]
here
oh yeah no i've done that i like the
fact that you had to wait until he was
alone
and yeah because because these other
boys were like
discussing you know how good the
alabaster rock in one piece was and i'm
like i don't think these boys are ready
for kisses
these these guys are like these guys
who sees the hidden potential in that
one student he's like i i can teach you
the way
you sense it you're ready to learn
you're ready to upgrade
so did he so did he enjoy more of that
kind of show afterwards
so then so then that was the point where
we basically
him and i we found out that we found out
from each other that we're
into those kinds of shows we're okay
with it
we're just into each other yeah we were
just into those kinds of shows
yeah because after we finished kisses
we're both just like
i gotta i just gotta let you know bro
now that we've had this [ __ ] like
journey together
that i'm like secretly into these shows
he's like
every single moment of this story you're
telling could be like a coming out to
each other
i'm kind of into these shows and then
from there and from there
mike's like i gotta get the [ __ ] out and
and yeah so so from then that point on i
i kind of was i became a lot more open
with like my
my my your your my my trashy taste in
anime right sure jojo is like yes i'm
hentai sexy
i'm right are you purposely picking
words
stop this i am writing look yowie
writers this is free real estate all
right like go
go for it but yeah but that was the
point where i slowly realized oh
if i'm closeted then yeah i'll obviously
have a lot of fun you know just
kind of enjoying this medium for myself
but yeah there's a whole other enjoyment
when you get someone else into it as
well